hey Vsauce Michael here and I've got
some good news today I'm bringing you a
bunch of Vsauce WTF s and hey those
always make people happy first a replay
from Pro Evolution Soccer 2008 the
goalie stops the ball and as we move
forward frame by frame but head at least
he knew to catch the ball not go under
it no no no no guys stay above ground
gosh dang it the only thing worse is
when friction just gives up now how is
it that this man defies physics easy
it's the shades check out my virtual
girlfriend I'm not sure how long it's
gonna stay in the App Store but you can
get it right now and the game allows you
to design a girlfriend take her on dates
and if you play your cards right see her
put on lingerie and even touch her or at
least the screen this downloadable map
is sweet the textures on the wall are
Minecraft but you're actually playing
left 4 dead we've seen Rube Goldberg
machines before but this digital one
created using Garry's Mod is epic
almost as epic as this character
animation sorry well no need to get
violent I just and yes those numbers are
real this video linked in the
description contains 101 different ways
he can die don't you hate it when cute
pictures go like this these sauces
covered crazy dancing before but this
guy seems possessed oh wait no he's fine
and doesn't it suck when someone can
crash faster than you can drive you
might as well play Mario Kart we crash
into a mountain and then drive up it
impossibly here's a cat plane
kinectimals with the Xbox Kinect and
here's somebody's dad dancing to Britney
Spears
in Dragon Age Origins the game doesn't
always understand beheading your victims
can still talk to you and get sassy
Donkey Kong 64 in game shark are great
together you can make RAM be the Rhino
fly or walk on his face the big deal
Mario can do that too that's it for this
episode of Vsauce WTF s but there's
plenty more
and you can click any of these to watch
other episodes and then click the little
button the lower left of those videos to
come back to this menu before you go
watch them let me know in the comments
below what game are you playing the most
right now for me honestly it's dragging
the huge origins look have fun and as
always thanks for watching